hallo leute ich hab heute das video
nicht mit musik hinterlegt oder sonst
irgendwie bearbeitet weil sich heute in
meinem persönlichen umfeld ein vorfall
ereignet hat aufgrund von dem ist mir
einfach nicht möglich war irgendwie
heute was zu schneiden oder sonstig zeit
zu investieren
außerdem ist der ton ein bisschen
komisch weil ich von luca die ton datei
bekommen habe und ja aber ich hatte halt
das fand ich schon fertig und ansonsten
halt nicht viel bearbeitet weil ich ja
ansonsten ein straight bekommen hätte
lade ich das heute ja und ja macht's gut
hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
gemeinschaft war meine damen und herren
wir schauen jetzt auf dem server
geschickt max ich hoffe auch ich hoffe
ich auch liegt direkt und ich liege ja
wir können nicht laufen kann nicht
laufen
okay okay okay du machst unser plan ist
es sind ja zwei leute bei uns das heißt
magst du machst die direkten work travel
habe ich habe ich habe ich hier bin ich
nicht man muss direkt eisen spitzhacke
und dann bauen wir uns quasi direkt weg
ok macht macht ganz schnell mal ganz
schnell sie sind nicht da luca sie sind
nicht da ich weiß immer ganz schnell es
nicht okay ich habe mich weg max jetzt
hinter mir cobblestone die sache ist
mister wargame und sein teampartner ins
detail sind neben uns und er deswegen
konnten uns in der letzten folge nicht
ausloggen hier mal ein kurzer ausschnitt
goldmines ok gold gefunden und da wollen
wir ab ist noch und die sind ist
offensichtlich nicht nachgezahlt
ja aber was bringt uns zum fall nicht
dass sie kommen sie da kommen okay okay
wir sind hinter uns diesem hintergrund
um mein gott oh mein gott mag setzt
hinter uns ja alles okay
hast du den granit hinter es ist
wir gehen jetzt einfach nach ganz oben
ganz ganz nach ganz oben und ganz oben
ja also wir haben einen dicken vorsprung
alles eigentlich dürfte gut gehen ja
aber die sind wahrscheinlich direkt
neben uns sie waren neben uns okay drop
mir mal bitte nach hinten cobblestone
kannst du das machen sofort
ich kann jetzt nicht grade nicht
weiterzubauen und okay ich habe es
gemacht du hast 64 ja ich habe 64 ich
habe mir eine spitzhacke ist ein fünftel
weg kann es mal schauen welche höher wir
sind endermann bisschen die richtung
dreh dich mal nach rechts und wie beim
hochbau
okay okay dass wir nicht immer nur die
gleiche richtung und bauen hier ist erde
hier sehr gut dann raus mit uns und dann
rennen wir einfach okay ich habe gerade
schon irgendwie so ein bug irgendwie den
himmel gesehen wird ich glaube so weit
ist es nicht mehr leute also nochmal
zusammengefasst die beiden sind hinter
uns und verfolgen uns wahrscheinlich
gerade und wir haben sie auf unsere
kosten wie haben sie auf twitter
versucht zu verarschen so von wegen okay
wir sind jetzt im restaurant essen und
so ein schiff war natürlich quatsch wir
haben nicht pizza essen also an alle die
das vielleicht bei twitter gelesen haben
am 27.11
das waren alles schon ältere bilder und
die beiden einfach glaube ich mich
gerade den berg rhein max so konnten wir
sind auf höhe 46 nähe alles als normal
viele der steine luca aber ganz ganz
kurz nur ein ganz kurzes nicken warte
kurz viele ich war ich oder wollen wie
es ohne ich habe angst luca
habt ihr gegeben kennst du wirst du
selbst wieder auf ihr kommen wir sind
hinter uns ich habe du hast nicht ein
licht gegeben luca gesehen habe ich nach
rechts weiter nach oben weiter nach oben
du stehst in die max weiter nach oben
luca weiter noch um
ich gebe jetzt eine ok luca bottich
weiter noch unfertig war da noch um fakt
die sind einfach hinter uns das machen
wir ja wieso sind wir noch nicht oben
eine spitzhacke ist fast kaputt werde
hier kommen gibt ja sogar dass er das
gerade das grab lauf junge ok lauf lauf
love love love love love love ok max wie
viele herzen hasst du wie viel ich hab's
geschafft sehen ich bin voll folge folge
findet okay lauf ich laufe ich laufe
laufen hinterher okay okay ich sehe sie
nicht hinter uns ich sie nicht
ich bin direkt hinter dir alles gut
gebraten ist nicht ok konnte damit
folgen wir folgt mir luca volkmer baute
ich irgendwo antworte ich irgendwo rein
max folgst du mir ja hast du oder hast
du spitzhacke ja ok dazu das ist keine
schnell schnell locker
die lizenz nicht gewesen und jetzt mache
ja ich sehe keinen ich glaube sichtlich
nicht fliegen um auf gar keinen fall ins
mieten
ich glaube sie hat nur noch er da hin oh
mein gott oh mein gott mit uns fliegen
einfach für ein apple store
ja sicher ist sicher setzt es hinter
mich irgendwie wir gehen noch weiter
rein aber nur ich glaube die haben uns
die haben uns wäre es nach der
hinzunahme seien einfach nicht bewegen
wurde jetzt der erste tag ist richtig
ich gucke genau zu dem namen hin quasi
er ich sehe den namen aber nicht mehr es
nicht auf jeden fall hier also halter
leute wir haben eigentlich eine
challenge wollen wir die chelsea zu den
namen wo dann oft eine andere richtung
okay nichts wie nichts abbauen nichts
machen einfach kein geräusch von uns
geben okay was wir sagen nichts wir
machen jetzt nichts tue
oh mein gott wenn ich du wäre würde ich
den finger von herrschaft junge leute
das war übel spannend gerade aber unser
eigentliche und die eigentliche tag
legen
unser doc aus in faro ist ja eigentlich
dass wir jede folge der neuen challenge
machen
die heutige challenge ist dass wir die
ja nein nicht challenge machen das heißt
das hat sasha grey und sympathisch schon
auf seinem kanal gemacht diese vier
begriffe darf man nicht sagen und bei
uns ist es so wenn man einen begriff
diese vier begriffe doch sagt muss man
sich selbst eine backpfeife geben ja ich
weiß nicht das fragen wir noch mal in
der disco gruppe nachher nach von
unserer von der wahl von den wahlleuten
hier
ob ich mag's fans können hier runter
dann gleich einblenden darf wenn er
leichte weise eines der vier worten
wörter sagt sonst seht ihr das hat mich
schon hört halt nur wie mag sich eine
klatsche gibt und bei mir erst dann
könnte es halt in max partner schauen
aber vielleicht sind ja eine feste
eingeblendet also ich würde sagen ab
jetzt einfach oder
positiv ich dachte bereits wirst du
verkackt hättest
mega trucks
das machen wir jetzt eigentlich wollen
wir die ganzen folgen wir uns schon so
verrückt wenn man das nicht sagen da
allein das wort wenn man so ich glaube
das ist aber unsere eigene hoffen unsere
einzige hoffnung dass wir diese los
angeles haben weil ansonsten bisher die
folge jetzt so langweilig
der schön es ist musik in meinen ohren
alter schwede gehen nicht niemals runter
von disney kaste
ich habe angst gerade dass die irgendwo
sind das die irgendwo roms nieten
glaubst du die sind noch über uns die
sind nicht über uns der name war schon
relativ weit weg ich würde sagen
war durch extra fahne damit ich
bestimmtes jj werk auch gott
aua
ich habe gerade zwei mal zwei der wörter
gesagt
deswegen gab ich mir eine backpfeife
also der name den ich gesehen habe war
locker 100 blogger entfernt wollen wir
zwar ungern ich würde am liebsten was
essen ich habe halt nur russ hühnchen da
kann man sich ja von vergiften ich würde
fast sagen ich auch gerade damit
vergiftet ich würde sagen wir wagen das
jetzt einfach ja aber
ein dummkopf schon wieder gerade das ich
musste heute dennoch geraten
junge luca alter später zu bescheuert
alter du hast es einfach bisher kein mal
gesagt stimmt und ich so ich glaube
jetzt mal ich sag ja auch nicht so viel
wie du ich rede ja nie so viel ich würde
er wirklich sagen luca wir wagen ist
jetzt einfach ist ihr sicher was sollen
wir denn sonst machen
andererseits wenn wir jetzt die ganze
folge abwarten würden bis die bis sie
aus gelockt werden dann verlieren wir
zwar eine folge aber sind nächste folge
wieder sicher weißt du das stimmt dann
müssen wir aber noch nicht mehr als drei
folgen produzieren oder gibt
wir haben noch gar keine change fürs
nächste mal ich würde sagen die wagens
jetzt einfach auf den markt weitergeben
was habe ich gesagt ich habe nicht
gefragt die dürfen noch drei nicht mehr
als drei folgen aufnehmen wollen wir
wollen wir vielleicht ja ich will nicht
tritt karl gehört ich bin du weißt was
du gerade gesagt hast was denn wie heißt
die challenge noch mal
hey sagt den anfang
vielleicht ist nicht dabei okay war echt
nicht fortgeschrieben lacker ich habe
seinen namen nicht gesehen aber
wir uns irgendwie locken so und die
jahre wartet ihr noch
ich mag dauern
j dass jj und das n wort gibt noch die
ganze zeit backpfeifen schon die maxi
sind locker hier irgendwie ja ich glaube
es auch backpfeife ich würde am liebsten
nicht irgendwo hin bauen
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe zu
viel spaß daran an diesem ganzen
challenge zeug und sowas als dass ich
will das jetzt war schon vor weiß man ja
gibt die reine los hab ich schon besser
aber du jetzt sitzen seit elf minuten
unter dem boden und beklagen uns ein
darüber ab dass wir die ganze zeit
wörter sagen ja da ist mir das ein name
der name des nagellacks
sie ist es okay gästen liegt bleiben
okay dann haben sie safe aufgegeben wenn
sie jetzt schon über uns sind
siehst du sie max was machen wir was
machen wir
ja hier bleiben ich weiß aber sie cent
liegt rumgerannt das heißt dass sie
nicht davon ausgeht dass wir hier unten
sind das was wir machen wir warten jetzt
einfach ab diese verdammte folge und
dann nehmen wir das bei den ringern uns
doch nicht ausladen ja auch was wir
warten einfach hier niemanden
du hast gerade übrigens das wort gesagt
hast du das ist wirklich mal da und
wieder ins nicht ich frage mich jetzt
nur es gibt ja das plug-in
dass man
sich nicht aus sagen kann wenn die in
der nähe sind
verstehst du ja wenn die natürlich
angezeigt kriegen sie kommt sie kommt
sie kommt gut weg
mein gott sie war so nah
alter
was jetzt hau ab hau ab jetzt ist sie
wirklich weg bis sie
der name ist soweit gerade entfernt
gewesen dass er quasi nicht mehr
angezeigt wurde
was würdest du jetzt hier noch warten ja
wann man was machen wir denn jetzt noch
hier weiter unsere folge ist 14 minuten
lang ich würde sagen 14 minuten wir
haben locker eine minute vorher geredet
ich glaube wir haben noch zwei minuten
wir müssen einfach zwei minuten hier
jetzt absage wir müssen einfach zwei
minuten abwarten und hoffen dass mister
morgen weiß aber es wird ja die ganze
zeit nur der name von ari angezeigt dass
mister x games nicht in der nähe ist
und ich würde sagen wenn da gleich steht
du kannst du nicht aus sagen das sind
gegner in der nähe dann bauen wir uns
sofort nach unten
das heißt du baust sofort nach unten
nach unten ja okay wir folgen der plan
du brauchst dich nach unten und dann
direkt wieder hoch woanders weißt du
dann laufen wir wieder oben an der an
der oberfläche weg
aber noch einen anderen wilster quasi
direkt abholen jaja marktreife 2 aber
nur möglich mit verlagen gefasst mag es
wenn da gleich steht du kannst dich vom
server geschickt werden weil leute in
der nähe sind wo sie haben ich mich hier
nach unten drei blöcke dann ganz lang
nach vorne sage ich mal
und dann irgendwo wieder nach oben und
wir laufen da sind die beiden da vorne
waren sie gerade und haben aufgehört
liegen und sie kommen auf uns zu
ok
ok jetzt müssen wir hoffen jetzt müssen
wir hoffen jetzt mittel bereit um dich
nach unten zu bauen und geht so weit weg
von den namen dem weg von mir geweckt
von max die beenden mal ganz kurz die
challenge jetzt schon mal okay jetzt
entspannt
yes yes yes ja man okay wir haben gesagt
luca will ich hebe das war so eng sorry
leute dass wir die ganze folge lang nur
unter der erde waren aber das war an
spannung pur wir haben auch ganz locker
genommen mit der challenge aber die
waren die ganze zeit bei uns quasi
oh mein gott aber die beiden denken doch
jetzt locker dass wir ganz woanders sind
oder her ist es scheißegal was sie
denken weil sie haben drei folgen
aufgenommen wir haben zwei aufgenommen
das heißt die direktoren während er noch
eine aufnehmen machen wir auch und wir
haben ab verdammt noch mal leute werden
das euch gefallen hat last man leichter
in der nächsten folge machen wir dann
wieder eine andere stadt entstehen an
die luft und kämpfen bisschen keine
ahnung was schaut auf jeden fall max
vorbei dass ich dir seine folgen werden
die backpfeife gegeben hat oder hab's
halt bei mir gesehen mit der face kennt
keine ahnung
die letzten worte gern wieder dir
abonniert uns beide und schaut weil
niemand anders war